welcome to this video about round three
of the candidates in London and after
this very timid round one we have a
really spectacular tournament now we had
two decisive games yesterday and today
it was really am a big fight on our
boards basically um let's start with
them the game kramnik against we shop
which in comparison really was some
rather less exciting let's put it this
way the a chronic plays g3 against
Greece shocks Knight f6 and g6 but
crucial cannot completely sure if he
intends to play the Kings Indian or the
groom felt I gasps g3 however he went
for the goon felt and we got the
well-known main line here I really don't
want to get into details this is a very
um sophisticated way to to play with
white those little moves like Age 3 are
important but I'm the wrong guy to ask
them what exactly is so great about to
move like Age 3 I don't know the theory
so basically what we got was this kind
of position let's put just a couple of
so very normal we see that like has a
slightly worse pawn structure but he's
got good pieces the night is active on
c4 this Bishop is active and while g7 is
not so great but those this mf5 and ce4
pieces are good and the chrome [ __ ]
actually managed to to even winner porn
somewhat later yeah but black can got
quite decent activity attacking both
bishops
dumb it's not so easy to make any any
progress inside maybe there was some way
to to make some headway but this chronic
didn't find anything we see that here we
had on perpetual and and game drawn it
is not possible for wide to really go
for anything if you look at this is what
played in the game and if white now
tries to continue with something like
this the problem is that it is very
difficult now to to find some
constructive plan if white for example
on tries to move the pawns here the
smooth a5 and you're even worse the
pieces are not very well coordinated on
alternatively let's say white will play
age form then there's also a five and
how do you how do you continue here
something like this won't amount to much
we even probably even need to be
cautious iam so I'm not much to play for
so this is why they made a draw um next
let's check sweet lord job of this was
much more interesting and swidler
playing before he really seems to have
abandoned the King's pawn for the moment
and Raja will finally goes for his trade
markings Indian and spittle are playing
f3 interesting it's not the most popular
line nowadays the sameish against the
Kings Indian but it is about a choice of
course Rajab replaced c5 this pawn
sacrifice white can now take this if you
want
this gives us a line but this is wrong
belief to be fine for black due to the
the dark squared weaknesses 97 if rd
three moves like that so weiter declines
this and we have this position where for
decades it was belief that 95 is the the
way to go and it's still on the main
line but your job of goes for 95 which
recently out rose to the fashion the
idea is to get some quick play in on the
queenside and what you really need to
look at here is the time this is very
interesting Sevilla has spent close to
nothing here and your job of as well but
look what happens now a six quite normal
you want to play the five but should be
two or played instantly vice villa and
now 30 minutes by raja baath yeah for
move 10 and this is simply simply a
shocking his his in an absolute
mainstream o-line and he spent 30
minutes on move tendances really amazing
his may be the number one expert on the
king's indian in the world and he
obviously doesn't have anything against
the sameish I mean what is this I doubt
I don't get it I mean White's moves are
completely normal like Roxy one what
what else I mean Queen d2 maybe quickie
to but Brooksie one is entirely logical
what what gal from played here and then
he spent a further two minutes for b5 ok
sorry ya need to change this now okay b5
and white white took it and here again
30 minutes 30 minutes for for this move
I mean what else you need to go to see
form and this is really a really
mysterious in the meantime look what's
witla did he spent three minutes and
this is not even with increment this is
pure three minutes he basically took the
time to write the moves down and
otherwise he simply played his
preparation and this is nothing
spectacular I mean it's completely
normal moose and certainly easy to
prepare and he obviously seems to have
caught a job of completely off guard
really really amazing and the next move
instantly castles 94 and immediately
Bishop g5 this was obviously all
prepared by bus Villa and yeah well this
is just more 15 I mean this is normal
that they have this prepared and none of
those moves over 24 too difficult and
look what happens through job of place
but should be seven he could have taken
on d2l be too but um this is also i'm
very unclear is of course poopy if your
opponent plays everything instantly and
Swilley uh continued to play quickly but
not like blitzing moves and here he took
on be to the thing is have a look at
this position if black doesn't do
anything radical soon then he will
simply be a pawn down it's some not a
regular bank oh it looks like I'm the
typical bank or pressure but if white
gets his pieces organized then he will
play f-4e 5 f-5 and so on it's not like
your typical simple play on the
queenside
so let's say OPA just just just for
instance white can can do various things
but the easiest is just like like this
be three the night moves somewhere I
don't know maybe maybe back is better
but what what what is happening after
and flag f4 and then you can can choose
various things f5 is dangerous on even
if I've at some point can be a problem
so he chose to to play a queen night XP
to spending further time we had to have
this this kind of exchange operation and
here this move which looks simply
terrible but maybe yeah this was the
relatively best chance if you don't take
this you won't even have a chance to get
the apron but he doesn't get the a pond
here anyway it simply led to to this
position to an end game to an end game
were still ahead 50 minutes more on the
clock a job of down to two and in
addition it is it is entirely winning
for white and it's not even difficult
technically the problem is look at this
position the rook covers the night the
night covers the pawn everything is
nicely coordinated and it's it's a
material advantage anyway with two
pieces against the rook plus the c5
coming and so will I did an efficient
mop-up job here you want further
material on d6 a couple of moves later
yeah until her job of plate this on for
for quite a while even in a really dead
loss position when he was forced to give
up multireal and here he resigned yeah
very strange game where a job offer was
unrecognizable the thing is this is
really just complete I mean a very
conventional line there's nothing
special he had that he doesn't have
anything prepared Issus is really
amazing um of course he couldn't reckon
thats Villa would play exactly the same
ish but it's an absolute main line of
the king's indian you need to have some
preparation you cannot start to think on
move 10 at this level and then have a
CREP a CREP banco afterwards it's really
really a bit amazing okay um next game
even shook Aronian i won't do this in
much detail it was very complicated and
hard to figure out what was happening
here also the time is very interesting
the time spent on in one shop with the
trauma from poor ski avoiding our
mainstream theory and did after a couple
of moves at transposase to another
Queens pawn opening the the Torah attack
yeah here in this position white play
some short castles normally but if one
stroke decided to go for something else
he took on f6 giving up the double
chappell and continued age for this
looks a bit like yeah accrued attack in
a blitz game intending Bishop takes age
seven but okay he obviously decided to
play in a non conventional fashion but
look what happens 96 and now I played 95
you cannot sacrifice now you but you
need to check out of course the thing is
this is in fact mating very easily even
but like it's not forced to take you can
go to h6 and this shirt should win
there's simply not enough firepower for
her white to continue there's no bishop
on f4 for example so this is not working
but 95 is interesting 36 must cover and
now he played F for covering this night
I was more expecting I'm Queen to g4
here this wouldn't have weakened the
destruction so much the thing is f4 is a
little bit of a yeah it it's really like
crossing the point of no return after
this why it is so so weakened here g3 g4
III everything is everything is weak
that you really need to get something
very concrete on the king or otherwise
your strategically in very bad shape and
aronian plate 97 queen to g4 and h5
blocking the Kings side and getting them
if you look at this b5 feel strong this
prepares the outposts on d5 for the
night and it's um yeah it's also a pawn
sacrifice but if white takes one shot
didn't with a three-wide takes him then
Queen B 6 for example gives black very
good play you don't even use the pawn
really okay you cannot take here now
maybe you can even look at this this is
the same yeah okay this is not good it
just opens up wide White's position the
eventual played a three Queen B 6 rook
g1 attending g4 probably and yeah it's
very um very complicated but have a look
Aronian has got one hour 23 minutes left
and the one shop is down to 21 minutes
and this is not not all of it he spent
much more time in the in the next couple
of moves before Baroni and it's a self
cause a very very direct move takes
takes and what happens if white now
takes on the phone there's a5 coming and
also deform and singing so f5 is the
strongest but you can also consider to
take this is hanging and black will have
a huge attack just look at that the
bishops f5 is stronger though yeah this
is what he won should play it is down to
nine minutes Queen to be five here
Aronian could have played Queen to c7
and this is even stronger this is a
possible continuation and now something
like this this controls the whole center
and black sim please got two bishops in
an open position who had his White King
go so it's simply a big advantage for
black what he played was also good for
an advantage this is so no doubt yeah
down to five minutes and of course it's
two nights against two bishops black is
clearly better
and now 44 seconds this is not one
hundred percent precise but very close
to it yeah now the ICC caucus is even on
a minus minus level it is not completely
accurate here of course it's not a minus
it's not possible with the game
continuing but even ship was down two
seconds like 15 seconds or something for
at this point and it's simply not
possible to play 15 moves in 15 seconds
or in 30 seconds for for that matter in
a position where where it is really am
really complicated he managed a couple
of more moves and ronnian didn't play
the best moves also but the thing is if
you are absolutely sure that your
opponent will lose on time you make
mistakes it's almost a given because you
know you will win on time and you don't
play that accurately anymore in fact
after this aronia played re5 and this is
not clear this is the best but it made
them even shook spend even more time
this was the idea a technical technical
shot if white now takes on before they
are simply rookie 5 and this is easy
winning the Queen but he's got this and
this is what he wants your plate with
his last seconds and yeah the remaining
moves were looked to be six this is in
fact the best move Queen B 6 Queen a
three and now black black is better even
yeah this is a very very strong attack
but the thing is eventually had no
chance to to to make the time control
there was this plate and I'm not sure
this was even plate because he I think
he overstepped the time at this moment
I'm not quite sure if that icc relay is
correct you but he overstepped the time
here or one move before um he had five
seconds here on the clock but he he lost
some time and it was basically no
question after me
25 around here that he will lose on time
it wasn't possible to to make these
moves and this is really not a good sign
because yeah you should spend your time
will be better and frankly this some
whole way of playing was a little bit
strange so let's hope that this isn't
getting a complete meltdown Holy One
shook it happened time and time again
when he had a bad start to a tournament
that GM would lose some games with yeah
really strange things happening um okay
so a win for omean he's in great shape
with plus two after three rounds I think
this is better than he even expected so
that's one game left calf on Carlton
let's do to that and the elephant lost
yesterday this game against Aronian so
Carlton probably wants to try a little
bit to to tickle him and maybe catch him
with some some yeah maybe provoke some
some some mistakes by a person who is a
bit shaken by this loss yeah causal
plates the Queens gambit declined here
okay this is not the most aggressive
opening ever but at least it keeps some
pieces on the board and it can lead to a
fight and in fact I'm geffen surprised
me a little bit by allowing the
Cambridge Springs this this line which
is not bad or anything it's a good good
way to to play against with white to
allow that but I thought given the
situation he would more go for the for
the exchange in this kind of line where
white can press with little risk for for
ages and it's very hard to lose um this
would also fit gaff on style nicely but
we didn't play that okay he went for
this which is no mistake of course yeah
the Cambridge Springs and really ancient
line in the Queens gambit declined where
traditionally the main moves are 92 and
in recent years he takes d5 and this is
the sharper move which in fact a galvan
plate he really went in for more pride
in our playbook c1 which is a bit a bit
of a rarity on the normal uses here
Queen d2 which can now lead two to this
and to quite interesting unbalanced play
very often this even in tangles upon
sacrifice on on this poem on c3 later of
course not not at the moment um but Roxy
one is a bit different because now black
has at least one additional option and
this is a what Carla played he took on
c3 and played Bishop a three so at the
first possible moment is he is playing
on the sideline so the same and Gavin
Ted 20 minutes spent already he wasn't
expecting this it seems why did he spend
the time actually this is interesting I
spent the time even here deciding to go
for the Cambridge Springs okay yeah
butcher Bay three this is the rebels
this has been only played two or three
times before at least in my database and
it's not such a small one so the idea is
push up a three it simply attacks the
book and it needs to go to the somewhat
ugly square C 2 and then be six it's
simply preparing bishop asics and the
next couple of moves are I think very
understandable you should basics
exchanging and castle so we have a
position where two pairs of minor pieces
have been exchanged and black them and
tends to play c5 later
doesn't have a bad pieces is good the
bishop on CA distr exchanged and this
has been played before in a game by now
it gets complicated by Russian Belgium
Turkish Grand Master Mikhailovich he
played for all these Federation's maybe
not for Russia maybe it was a Soviet
Union back then then he played for
Belgium then for Turkey and now he's one
of those coaches of the Turkish national
team he had played this last year in the
tournament and had a good position on so
it was not completely new concept that
Carlton played here but he used the rare
rare line again yeah here of course they
are multiple I'm sorry multiple ways to
play as wide get one chose to to take
the center with you for which cannot be
bad really droopy 8 freeing f8 for some
peace bishop or night both might make
sense and now we five and I really don't
like this move so much it's not them
it's not bad yeah but it leads to a
position where I always have the feeling
that white needs to prove something that
he really has the quality I'll show you
what I mean a little bit later um I have
a look h6 winning a tempo and c5
and now we see what happens black
exchanges here and now we have this
position where D Phi has a weak spot if
m and okay this is just theoretical
possibility black would now be able to
sort of yeah beaming the snide to defy
from g 725 he would have a brilliant
position with this outpost on d5 and
black has got two against one on the
queenside so I'm in this position the
only thing that black needs to do is get
the night to defy that have a really
nice advantage white some ideas are
based on something to d6 maybe maybe
from seafoam and I it's got some space
but I always feel that this is not so
great for white with lots of pieces
exchanged and we have quite some
exchanges already cars just plays rook
c8 and this is technically interesting
because this move right at first looks
very good but he has Queen B 5 and this
is said a nice way here to to use the
pin right um now cannot win any material
on a three Queen a three there's just
Lucy form like it's ok yeah girl from
platform this looks active but it also
sort of weekends White King a bit whoops
yourself just simple chest intending to
to double on the C file and now why
didn't see anything better than get rid
of this this opinion situation Bishop f2
was necessary to God deform and this is
exactly the kind of position I was
talking about just imagine black would
be able to get this in 925 then this is
simply a terrible for white and white
needs to avoid the sinner
and it's summer fields to me that what
needs to be precise already it's not too
difficult to do probably but this is why
I didn't like in five so much but it's
not it's not bad objectively but the
create some it feels like white should
have had something better night MA
they're intending exactly this course g3
protects a form and i will see eight of
course black wants to get rid of the
rook important thing is if you look at
this if why it goes here which looks
good at her side black Scott queen a six
and has some nice play against a tune
and they're they're even possibilities
to two in wait here if white for example
drops the route back then there's Queen
III worth already a big advantage for
black so in the game Glavine play G
three ropes the eight getting rid of the
rocks and now the important move d5 this
was necessary you don't want to allow
any kind of thing like let's say what
can y do beside the d5 is very natural
but let's say you place move like this
year then black will probably go here
control the g5 square and then intent
the men should regroup in with the big
to catch at the end this is why g5
getting rid of this pawn it took and now
set up a good position on the kingside a
three-year just keep the porn protected
here and h5 and here Galvan played a
surprising move which really am yeah it
did surprise many title players when I
was looking at the live broadcast he
played each form putting a pawn on dark
squares is really somewhat strange with
this bishop it weakens the light squares
and it hampers your ideas of campus is a
good word h3g for is not possible
anymore he had a very concrete idea and
it seems this wasn't really a bad idea
but it needed precise play and look at
the time this is very important Black
has got 45 minutes extra and this is
quite huge this is logical because white
were threatening at five if Blackwood
player would have played some some slow
news than theirs f5 coming and white has
chances now against the king this is why
this was played controlling the square
and now what activated to the Queen and
we had a couple of more moves well I am
okay so yeah I had this that is wrong
here cosplay be fighting and allowed f5
to continue the fight this is a really
typical he always tries to keep the game
going and pose some problems and look
what happened to him I've got this
exchange he took the a pawn of course
got 12 gauge five so the king is exposed
black skin here and now check King evade
and now delford had about two minutes on
the clock this is just roughly two
minutes you don't know exactly if it is
two minutes two minutes 10 11 minute 50
seconds something like this and here
delfin could have drawn the game and in
a very straightforward fashion with the
Queen age five but it didn't you play
age five green at five and was much
better intending Queen to age 8 and this
is really a draw like has no way to to
get out of this especially if you look
at this here it's not just a matter of
checks there's also the H point and this
here um forces a draw because the H porn
is actually quicker than the black spots
but cannot push the his own paws the
future if he goes here and tries to push
himself then this is even of course
winning for white it's very quickly
earth to spawn so I'm black must allow
it wrong I can he can always play
something like this and start to give
checks himself so Queen h5 would have
drawn but it's move 40 mm and very
unlucky for girlfriend she only had
little time played h5 which doesn't look
so bad as as well but that's allowed
Queen to see one and now suddenly the
queen is covering age 60 that pawn to h6
is not possible and how does the White
Queen now get to the king he tried
Queenie falls in sensible move and Carly
pushed there should be three attacking
the Queen and here i think car's owner
had to had a better option at least if
you look at this with an engine it dumb
it gives queen to see eight instead of
Queen c7 as stronger but it's very
difficult and i'm also not one hundred
percent convinced really because i am
had limited time to to analyze this and
it's very tactical of course you cannot
simply give it to a computer and it
tells you we are this and that
you need to look a bit bit deeper and
this is very tricky in this position
Prince EA does maybe better on a general
level because it simply prevents Queenie
a check and it's not so clear how I
should proceed to a queen h7 is probably
the toughest idea going for various
checks but this is answered by Queen c6
check king f2 and now the beep honest
sorry to roll a possible continuation is
here check another check I think now
this is stronger h6 Quincy to for
example be 2h7 a very very sharp because
yeah we've got possibilities for four
queens on the board the best however is
going to have five check queen and now
this funny way not taking kingly six is
much stronger King b6 Queen and now look
like a form and this is a clear edge for
black the king is more active but it is
not insecure simply because this night
is such a great defending piece and
whites king is very exposed this is a
big advantage for black maybe it's
winning but this is all very difficult
to assess if you look at this it from
move withstand moves deep this line and
I'm not even sure if this is in any way
forced the computer says simply Quincy
Aden wins but I'm not one hundred
percent convinced causal played this um
at least and girlfriend gave this check
there was also age six possible but it's
not not a big difference now I place h6
really form
and now king a queen Queen to d8 of
course cards and wants to continue and
here's something very curious happened
and this is really am showing that
galfond is not in top shape here here
wide of course just must go to g6 to c6
to c6 keeping the Queen on the board and
it's not clear if this is some um yeah
if white can draw this it's not clear at
all but you need to try this is the only
way to to even try for something like
and continue in various ways you can
play be 3y are all night f8 it's very
very tricky to analyze I think black has
good winning chances but you need to try
to do that what he did is he exchanged
Queens and went into dead lost endgame
and this is really easy and I really
don't know what maybe he had some simple
miscalculation sometimes even the best
players just um gap over look I'm a
really simple thing just just a couple
of weeks ago I had to add an endgame
we're simply counted wrong I mean simple
one plus one plus one and simply
miscounted and lost very very stupid if
you look at this you think I'm brain
dead um ok so here cars and just needed
to push the pawns and it's very easy
then the odds tactic of course Bishop a5
be too and it promotes and that's it
simply it's easy he just promotes the
pawns or here again we got a queen
yeah gia girlfriend resigned blackwall
promote on alternatively you can sack
here and get into this end game that
black simply picks up those two points
and wins yea rather typical win for
cousin from not much she managed to
create some chances and then also here
going at wife would have drawn but he
keeps the pressure on yeah he here again
he had 30 seconds 30 minutes more on the
clock so on Gelfond needed to decide on
a move with just two minutes left and he
he simply picked the wrong one maybe
miscalculating something along the way
and after that Carlton had excellent
winning chances and he won at the end so
after three rounds we have Aronian
leading with plus to excellent score
followed by carson and swindler maybe
but a bit of a surprise but i had a
slight idea that swidler maybe would do
would do well if you if you have the
chance have a look at the video coverage
of london if you have seen photos of
swidler before he must have lost about
40 50 pounds of something and looks
really fit so maybe he did some some
fitness program and really tried to
tried his best at this shot at the world
championship match maybe it's the last
shot that he'll he'll ever get you never
know and he really looks like he's in
good shape from a physical point of view
and this is very important for such a
tournament at least he he won today so
he's got plus one exactly like ours
who's in the hunt Kramnik and we shook
on fifty percent or drawers and
girlfriend and garrett above 150 percent
as well one lost one win and Gelfond and
Yvonne Shull are both
on- to at the bottom of the field it
doesn't look good they both seem out of
shape vanship with terrible time
management and gaff and yeah it doesn't
seem to have the sharpness that is
necessary for for such such a big event
yeah I hope you enjoyed the video
tomorrow is a rest day in London they do
rest days every three rounds so um round
four will be played on coming Tuesday
when I will be doing a video again of
course yeah thanks for watching I'll be
back on Tuesday